hundreds of military families have had
access to fertility treatments in recent
years but not all veterans qualify for
them according to the Department of
Veterans Affairs 567 families have
benefited from in vitro fertilization
since the military started covering the
procedures back in 2016 but veterans who
were single and want to have children
still have to pay for the roughly
$12,000 treatment on their own CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Michelle Miller
is here with the story of one Army
veteran who was calling for change
Michelle good morning to you she
certainly is good morning after serving
in the United States Army for 16 years
Tony Hackney decided to start a family
in retirement complications meant
exploring in vitro fertility treatments
when Hackney looked to Veterans Affairs
it would not pay because she isn't
married
Tony Hackney said she'd always planned
on being a mom but the call of duty
complicated her ambitions whether people
like you not as a female in the military
if you not they're more than your male
counterpart das are you kidding from
both it or getting a good evaluation
it's not it's not there she ultimately
rose to the rank of Staff Sergeant and a
military career that took her all over
the world I'm a veteran I have to be
married but yeah a male veteran wife can
get idea but I can't answer that trend
this doesn't make sense to me but being
married is not the only requirement to
receive IVF benefits qualifying veterans
must also prove a service-connected
condition that causes infertility have a
male spouse who can produce sperm and a
female spouse who can produce eggs is
taking away my life dream of bear mother
Hackney said an illness caused her
infertility while on active duty a
doctor at the VA suggested IVF could
lead to a family in retirement the cost
however was on her I need
and to feel that love that only your
child could give to you I need to have a
decent chance at that and they just said
like no big deal a House bill was
introduced last month to expand coverage
of fertility treatments including IVF to
all veterans
Tony Hackney is hoping that it becomes
law in time for her she makes a very
compelling story yes certainly doctor
she says it really it doesn't make sense
yeah male veterans their wives not in
the military but they get the benefit
and she doesn't she's actually veteran
she fought for her country she wants to
fight for her own life should you be
sending this report to somebody in the
middle of here yeah hopefully they're
all ready to see you're right Tony he'll
show better watching don't get me in
trouble
thank you very much good to see you